this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today because you guys undeniably
wanted to see more of it
he's going to be breaking down even more
of the guns in escape from tarkov
it's safe to say that he remains
impressed by the game maybe a bold
statement but it's got to be the best
gun game that i've ever seen and i
haven't even played it
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down
let us know in the comments section
below make sure to subscribe for more
videos exactly like this
and if you want to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
okay i think i think someone's messing
with me
my first thought when i saw the the ak
with no top cover
no rear sight no butt stock was what's
happened to that poor thing seeing the
inventory screen clearly those parts
have been taken off to demonstrate
what happens if you do that i mean
without having hands on can't be i can't
be sure but it looked a little bit
too easy to be able to squeeze off
vaguely accurate shots with no rear
sight and no butt stop
with practice i'm sure you could pull
that off but um i'd expect to be a bit
more all over the place
with that but there was a clear
improvement when the site went on when
the when the bus stop went back on of
course in real life
you'd have to get a screwdriver out and
then screw the butt stock on because
we're not talking about a later more
modular weapon whether parts just come
off without tools i love the fact that
the gun the guns are modeled in
the virtual world essentially as they
are in the real world and that's what
enables you to
break them down in that way and have
them configured in different ways
maybe a bold statement but it's got to
be the best gun game that i've ever seen
at this point and i haven't even played
it
okay i gather people have been keen for
me to see the
gunsmith section of of tarkov and i can
see why
that's really really impressive the
sheer variety that we see in here
cosmetic as well as what looks like some
pretty practical changes that you can
make
um i think i'd probably spend my most of
my time
in that section of the game and not
actually shooting anybody because
the ability to virtually customize
guns like that is that's practically a
game in itself that's really good
i really like that i'm gonna have to get
a second mortgage and get a gaming pc
the mosin rifle 1891 is when this thing
was first introduced so it's
uh seriously long in the tooth now but
so many were made and it had such a long
service
and manufacturing life and history that
there are an awful lot of them around
any bolt action rifle is going to put
you at a disadvantage
unless you're at some distance away so
i'd imagine
most players are using this as a sniper
rifle
with the scope otherwise people with
assault rifles that have optics will be
counter sniping you left right and
center but it certainly has the power
when the mosin first appears in the clip
there threw me off because
the the player characters aiming it like
there's nothing wrong but if you look
really closely
the front sight is actually missing so
i'm used to seeing
the ability to take parts off modern
modular weapons
and obviously in this game you can go
mad and take all sorts of parts away and
swap them
with others this vintage bolt action
rifle with no front sight
head scratcher at first but then you
realize the depth of the game and that's
what you're dealing with so you've got
to find yourself a new front sight
if you find a good one it's going to be
an accurate rifle get the right scope on
it
and it would still hold its own as an
inaccurate rifle today without without
slighting the mosin it's not the fastest
bolt to operate in the world
the bolt is always gonna slow you down
uh and you can see that in the way it's
animated but again if you're in cover
far enough away that 762 round is going
to do some
serious damage and allow you to do that
from a feral distance as well
wow well i'm glad i don't own that
firing range
that's um that's pretty cool gun named
um mjolnir
for obvious reasons i think it is pretty
thor's hammer in its
uh impact sound and uh they've captured
that beautifully there i've not i've not
fired or
seen that rifle fired in real life but
um my 538
lapra magnum sounds uh pretty every spot
on it's a very
powerful cartridge it's the very sort of
top end of
a anti-personnel rifle cartridge
we we're familiar with 50 bmg things
like the barrett
it can be used successfully as
long-range sniper rifles because of the
sheer power of the cartridge
but they're not ideal for it what's
ideal for it
is 338 lapa magnum
so the one on the bottom is 762
nato and a 338
magnum round so you can see that's the
propellant capacity is greater
the bullet is longer thicker heavier
it's going to do more damage
so yeah an interesting choice for the
game um means you've got a real spread
of
everything from pre-world war ii
military surplus to the very latest
precision rifles from from the west
are you gonna pause there i think this
is the
ds arms version of the fm
fal or the foul as people tend to call
it a little bit old-fashioned these days
the tilting bolt is does not lend itself
to
great accuracy the top cover isn't great
for mounting optics
but it's good i think it's good to have
some more legacy weapons
in a game like this for variety as in
all other aspects they've really nailed
the fal here you have those
slightly awkward old-fashioned iron
sights that don't give you the best
sight picture so that's
that's realistic you've got the way the
way the the sights are moving between
shots
because of the recall the simulated
recoil is excellent depending on how
it's held
the angle and how how frequently the
trigger is being pressed
the sight picture is changing which
again sort of reflects
real use of a real weapon then when we
go automatic which
most fal variants do permit the more you
hold down the trigger the more movement
there is
and it looks it's a sort of realistic
impression that's given
so yeah really good
hey falls in there there we have a chris
vector submachine gun being used
surprisingly effectively
as a um sort of pocket sniper rifle
obviously it's not designed for that
role it's meant to be a um a close range
weapon submachine gun
very interesting design that emerged not
that many years ago
it's rare that something uh genuinely
new comes along in the firearms world
it's sufficiently new that we don't have
one it's uh an attempt to i think we see
this
um represented pretty faithfully in the
in the way that the gay
the um gun is modeled and depicted is to
try to redirect the recoil impulse
downwards but yeah it's good to see it
in the game for some some visual
and mechanical variety really again it's
come a little bit late in the story of
the submachine gun to get any
real widespread adoption in the real
world
i'm just going to pause there we've got
the the saga 12 shotgun here which comes
in various
shapes sizes configurations the first
thing we see in that
in the clip is that the the shotgun's
jumping around all over the place
which although this is a semi-automatic
shotgun if you
um if you spam that trigger whether it's
the real thing or
in the game you're going to need some
serious skill to keep the muzzle
on target because the the cumulative
recoil of a 12 ball
12 gauge cartridge five shots in a row
is significant
it does it fits the the cqb uh
requirement in the game quite nicely uh
we've got a similar
example here from the collection this is
a kalashnikov derived
design scaled up for whacking great
12-gauge cartridges because it's a box
magazine
and the cartridges are so huge single
stack so if you want more capacity
you've got to get an ever bigger longer
magazine at the bottom or you do see
drum magazines as well
drums induce their own potential for
stoppages though
so um in this fictional setup probably
box magazines makes
sense
pausing there shotguns are extremely
versatile
weapons the interesting thing of course
is the change of ammunition so
we see a switch to slugs you can
pretty much you can custom load
ammunition to do whatever it is you want
to do buckshot is
is a good sort of all-purpose load
because it gives you that increased
chance of hitting and definitely
increased chance of stopping somebody in
their tracks
not quite as we see in a lot of more
unrealistic games where the spread is
just insane
it's a trade-off made for gameplay
purposes so you can't shoot anyone
beyond
five meters or something like that
that's not what we see in tarkov we see
buckshot being probably about as
effective as it would be
and then switching to solid slug so the
modern day musket ball and that will
carry
effectively and relatively accurately
for more than 100 meters
potentially the the flexibility with
ammunition is in all the weapons in
tarkov is
really cool shotgun is perhaps the
oldest flexible weapon
that exists now if we think of a shotgun
in terms of flintlock's percussion
all the way to the present day
the the dragon of svd this being the
svd-s
shorter barrel and folding stock the
original svd is
an 800 meter rifle in the sense that you
can hit a person at 800 meters
not perhaps as precise as some other
designs in that you can't necessarily
put a group of shots
in close proximity at 800 meters what
i'm
really taking with here is the depiction
of the scope when you see the pso
scope get clamped onto the rifle the way
the the reticle
is copied from the from the real thing
illuminated
switch that on and off which is amazing
i don't know without experience of the
game
what the sort of bullet drop is like uh
typically
sniper rifles and games go for a mega
bullet drop
for gameplay reasons especially if their
draw distance isn't that far
so battlefield has hugely exaggerated
drop of bullets this this seems to be a
lot more realistic on that score
the way the um what's called the eye box
is simulated so that the black
around the edges until your eye is in
the right place if you have this and vr
and that worked in that way that would
be extra immersive
so yeah really good
the ump is an odd one the way it's
depicted in the game is it's almost
getting boring saying this but really
good
the it's quite a short weapon and a
short barrel weapon and in 45 there's
still a
bit of punch from that uh cartridge and
it's not a locked or delayed breach
so that sort of rocking effect that we
see
in the clip is pretty much how it's
gonna get how it's gonna look
when you shoot it it'll tend to rock
back and forth in your shoulder
very much as we see there
okay causing that sig sauer um
has seen quite a lot of success in in
real life with
the mcx series of rifles and in common
with
many modern firearms it's actually
marked sig mcx
multi-caliber this one has a 5x6
barrel on it and the magazine is marked
556.
typically uh clever conversion requires
changing the bolts some of the other
aspects as well
with this it's just the barrel because
300 blackout is a larger bullet than
5.56 well in theory you'd only need to
change the magazine
um but it's a good idea to have separate
magazines for 300
and 556 because you can blow your gun up
i'd be very interested to know
if you can blow your mcx up if you can
change canvas
so uh answers answered in the comments
perhaps
so yeah i got a good depiction there i
like the the very the meaty sound
effects of those big
relatively big chunky 300 blackout cases
bouncing off the inside of that shipping
container it's a really good sound
design in this game
thanks everyone um those were some more
guns from escape from tarkov which i'm
increasingly interested in it's a real
step forward in the depiction of
firearms and video games
if you feel that you'd like to we do
have a donation
facility on the website it's linked in
the description above
and you might want to look at our
membership program but no pressure
thanks very much guys
you